faire les courses en ce jour férié à
auxerre difficile mais pas impossible
la plupart des magasins du centre ville
sont fermés mais les auxerrois ont leurs
habitudes
le seul supermarché du centre-ville lui
est ouvert jusqu'à 13 heures
et c'est là que les auxerrois viennent
faire leurs courses ça change rien je
fais mes courses comme d'habitude c'est
souvent ouverts n'y a pas de souci moi
j'aime bien quand les magasins sont
ouverts parce que ça fait de la vie
voilà c'est ça sinon le centre ville est
un peu mort pas beaucoup de magasins
ouverts mais un peu moins de monde dans
l'est dans les rues également aussi donc
c'est vrai que ça transforme un peu la
ville parce que on a l'impression de se
retrouver à dimanche après midi
y'a pas grand monde et pour faire
quelques emplettes cet après-midi mieux
valait quitter le centre ville et ses
devantures fermé pour vous rendre
jusqu'à la zone commerciale moins de la
moitié des magasins étaient ouverts et
des clients loin de s'y bousculer pour
cette commerçante ouvrir les jours
fériés reste problématique
c'est un peu compliqué parce qu'en fait
il y en a qui choisissent d'ouvrir et
donne non donc en fait les gens sont un
peu perdus et ne savent pas si l'aja
n'est ouverte qu'aux ouverte donc n'a
pas vraiment beaucoup de monde en fait
les boutiques de textile disent avoir
moins souffert des nombreux jours fériés
du mois de mai comme ce magasin de
chaussures la plupart ont fait le choix
d'ouvrir ici
la responsable espère une bonne journée
mais pas vraiment un boom de son chiffre
d'affaires en province comme ça c'est
sûr que c'est ça reste toujours moins
intéressants que dans des grosses villes
comme paris lyon
voilà où là vraiment l'influencé et la
même jour férié ou pas jours fériés
est-ce rentable ou pas d'ouvrir un jour
férié
la question semble diviser les
professionnels dans les villes moyennes
comme auxerre les grandes enseignes et
les zones commerciales ont plus tendance
à le faire
au contraire des petits commerces
indépendants